- Nice to meet you.
You look like you're
going to give me trouble,
so I'll much sure yours is the only name
I memorize this week.
(fast-paced techno music)
- You don't have to come to my prom later.
The leftovers are my groceries anyways.
- I can tell that you're drunk,
but we don't technically
have a policy against it
so I'm pretending not to notice
so I don't have to document it.
- When I'm doing room inspections,
I'm judging you by the stuff you have.
(speaks foreign language)
- I'm only asking for
your ID so that you know
I'm documenting this.
I pretty much have your information
memorized by now.
- Please just take these condoms now.
So we don't have to have that
awkward conversation later.
- I know who you are
and I've told you so many times
to keep your ID with you,
I'm just gonna let you sit out there
for a little while.
- I have three papers due tomorrow.
Do you really think I want
to write this report as well.
- I really don't agree with
your side of the argument
but I have to act impartial so
just keep spouting nonsense.
- Love the dorm. Drink in your room.
It really doesn't bother me.
But if you mess with my door tags,
then it's on.
(fast-paced techno music)
(swishing)
(light piano music)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah, hm mm. (swoshing)
(swishing)
(quick pop)
(quick swish) You don't
know the half of it.
(light piano music)